but first no matter how the biden
administration
tries to spin it there's a very real and
growing crisis
on our southern border lord by biden's
amnesty promise a pathway to citizenship
and the loosening of border restrictions
there is now a surge of new illegal
immigrants
pouring across the border many of them
are decked out
decked out actually in full biden
campaign gear
i never saw it on the campaign trail but
you're seeing it here
some are wearing t-shirts and carrying
signs that are saying
biden please let us in many of the
migrants are
unaccompanied minors just last week over
2000 of these kids
they were intercepted by border patrol
and according to the dhs
a record get this 117
000 unaccompanied children are expected
at the border this year
117 000 and of course the
biden administration is totally
completely unprepared
now they have already reopened a
facility for minors where children are
now housed
in a few tents those cargo shipping
containers with bars on the windows but
we are told
there are pictures of butterflies on the
walls you want to live in a cargo
container
the media is completely banned from
looking at these cargo
shipping containers inside them now
remember a few years ago when donald
trump was president
the mob the media even joe biden went
ballistic over scenes like this
and these and accused trump of putting
children in cages
those cages were built by biden and
obama the video was from the biden obama
era but
now in the middle of winter the bite
administration is putting these kids in
plastic tents with t with foil blankets
no one in the media mob seems to care at
all now
sarah carter is at the border tonight
you'll join us in a moment
in a moment obtain these images from one
of the emergency
shelters on the border and in the middle
of a pandemic there appears to be no
room for social distancing
and little more than a tarp for shelter
on the campaign trail remember biden was
vowing to treat migrant families and
children
with compassion and sensitivity
well is this the kind of compassion and
sensitivity
that joe's talking about or was it all
bs like the unity promise
what do you say for example jen saki
will never have a chance to ask biden
himself
maybe he'll circle back and answer these
questions about joe putting kids in
tents
with foiled blankets and shipping
containers with bars on the window
and meanwhile there are so many adult
crossings illegally
that the biden administration has now re
instated the obama-era policy
known as catch and release in other
words illegal immigrants that are
detained by border patrol
they are merely released into a u.s city
if they just promised to show up for
their scheduled court date
95 percent never show up and we know
that as a fact and get this according to
a brand new report tonight
over a hundred of these illegal
immigrants who were released in texas
yep they've since tested positive for
covert 19.
in the middle of a pandemic you think
the biden administration
might try extra hard to secure the
border
prevent the spread of covert 19 but
instead
the exact opposite is true by the way
you better wear your mask and you better
hide in your
basement but illegal immigrants no mass
mandates for them according to joe biden
only a neanderthal would lift covert
restrictions on americans
well joe you're inviting people in and
they're not social distancing and
they're not wearing masks
and many of them now we now know have
covet take a look
i think it's a big mistake look i hope
everybody's realized by now
these masks make a difference we are
on the cusp of being able to
fundamentally
change the nature of this disease
because of the way in which we're able
to get
vaccines in people's arms we've been
able to move that all the way up to the
end of may to have enough for
every american to get every adult
american to get a shot
and the last thing the last thing we
need is the neanderthal thinking that
in the meantime everything's fine take
off your mask forget it
all right let's all get this straight
according to biden illegal immigrants
they can pour across our
southern border no masks no social
distancing no covet tests nothing
but american businesses you have to be
shut down
indefinitely that makes zero sense and
tonight
if biden really wants to protect the
lives of we the american people of you
and your family
and migrants by the way shouldn't he be
doing everything in his power to deter
illegal immigration oh let's see maybe
do background checks on people that
enter our country
maybe do some health checks maybe make
sure people are able and capable of
providing for themselves
so they don't take jobs away from the 17
million americans out of work
because of the pandemic or now the
energy sector workers that all lost
their jobs because of
you know stroke of a pen by joe biden
now this isn't just about spreading
covert 19
but also the real dangers of human
trafficking look at this suv can you
imagine an
suv carrying 25 people
25 illegally crossed people into the u.s
from the mexican border through a hole
in the border wall
you know the one lindsey graham reported
on on this show that vehicle then
crashed into a truck
and killed 13 of the passengers now keep
in mind
one of joe biden's first actions of
president was to halt
all border wall construction sadly
biden's virtue signaling
has very real consequences this
resulting in death and i do fear
that the situation at the border is only
going to get worse here now